today's a good day you know why today's
a good day Marsh
because I didn't have to use
here we go yep yep yep yep yep it's a
good one too
I hate my brother
so let's get after it and have a spot
a good [ __ ] bread it is some good
Pokemon I'm sure you've seen on Twitter
people tagging us like can you please
just send me the question yeah I think I
want to show my friends non-stop with it
I want to show my friends but at Joy of
pessie
he has it
um
so uh oh God okay we got two we got to
not from the podcast performance Big
Time news Nation show
I want you to read the title of the
video so you know where this is going
qualo become a critical thinker
use your [ __ ] you know you're [ __ ]
Noggin over here here we go first off
check out the premise
if you could wave a wand and change
something for everyone what would it be
make everybody rich
live forever
my choice
the motivation for the creation of this
show and my podcast I would make
everyone an active and Avid and
aggressive critical thinker so you
wouldn't cure Childhood Cancer we had
this magic one I'm gonna play his game
all right I want to play Chris Como's
hypothetical
um you wouldn't cure Childhood Cancer
starvation no no you wouldn't you
wouldn't do any of that right you know
what I would do if I could get a magic
wand and wave it and I got one wish I
would wish for people to argue even more
I would wave it and get a magic wand
that lets me do more than one [ __ ]
thing because that's a shitty one that's
I don't know if you allowed to do that
if I had a wand I I would wave it around
in a manly fashion
and I would give the world all the spagu
they want
so many of them and then he's got like
the dumb cousin it's like well so you
can only use it one time why don't you
charge it first or something shut up in
your mouth
problems bye Chris why don't you wish
from our wishes Shut up
I'm not going to be taking stupid calls
like this all day all right I'm not
doing anything
uh yeah
just wish for more wishes that's just
stupid all right you can't do that why
you guys keep focusing on the one
thank you democritical thinking
about the one now let's get on to some
more critical thinkers uh Mark and Sia
said what are you doing out there yeah I
I don't think uh magic wands exists
Chris
look you're not you're missing what I
wanted forget about the one you guys are
focused like he said you're focusing on
the wine too much let's get off the box
it's not the wand
s hang up on this guy what are we doing
here what are we doing
get me better call us Chris I don't know
if you know this but news Nation runs
off a stream deck okay so there ain't
much I could do here but I'm using a
Discord yes so just anybody can kind of
pop in he sign up for the news Nation
Discord live chat with uh Chris Como he
starts at Discord in first day it's just
N word N word k word cozy dot TV Nick
sucker out of here get that Jeff Zucker
guy out of here
foreign
[Laughter]
our own lives would benefit so greatly
if as individuals and in the collective
we just harnessed our ability to
separate facts from feelings to weigh
the basis of what's being suggested okay
I am setting assistance immediately
to consider both sides of an argument
to go from left and right is that
when somebody comes up to you and says
hey why are you outside breaking
quarantine this is and then you call him
a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] yeah you scream
at him yeah an old man on a bicycle
to consider why we may be wrong you got
to consider both sides of the argument
hey Chris why don't you talk to your
brother ever state of understanding what
about this one remember this one
just get it we're done fighting with you
people yeah just get this vaccine all
you need to just not let these people
live on was that like considering
everyone's Side and being a critical
thinker no
and the Bittersweet part is I like that
he's watching he's wearing suits from
the [ __ ] a Scorsese collection what
is this about Mike well no I'll tell you
what it's about it's the same reason why
they're not as good looking as the CNN
suits because he's wearing his suits
from home
good point there's no hair made up in
[ __ ] there's a wardrobe at news
Nation now let Chris wear your own suit
and didn't even spring for the lapel mic
that matches the suit like they do with
the big fancy this [ __ ] guy is
bringing his suits he's getting he's
getting himself the news Nation he's
bringing his suit with the [ __ ]
plastic over it from the drawing USA or
something yeah and he's probably there
in some [ __ ] Adidas sweatsuit like a
guido and then he comes in free agent
free agent tank top free agent tank top
yo this hoodie is Hoodie in his [ __ ]
and his Adidas sweatpants and he comes
in and he's like oh I got a chance of
course has the wife beater underneath of
course
pasta sauce on it of course
buddy being rich your world peace Chris
you know we how tiny do you think his
little gold chain is that he has under
there I'm just curious do you think it's
a real tiny one
is it the Italian horn the Italian of
course well I'm such an idiot of course
it's an Italian horn so you know
everybody living Forever Chris Chris you
know we have suits here at the studio no
this suit belonged to my father
my father
what I would I would give you here's
Cuomo if I had to imagine Chris Cuomo is
the kind of guy who is who chooses
excellent colognes that wears entirely
too much
he's like the [ __ ] from undateables
like really good cologne but like look I
know the Armani cologne smells nice but
the half the bottle Chris hey sometimes
less is more baby you know his wife on
the way out maybe sometimes less is more
she has to lower the window and the
winner in the car because she's crying
from the smell of it she's their kids
have asthma
wife rolls down the window or ice or
water and he just looks at her unaware
just like oh what did you fart or
something
unlike the other wand Advance mine oh my
God he's back to the wand I didn't go
back he's back to the wand
unlike the other wanded wants mine could
actually I could wave this wand I let
the whole world taste this bread so he
just said unlike the other magical wand
which mine could actually happen Okay
then you don't need a wand yeah
then I would have used the one for
something you really need a wand for
yeah Chris this way you got fire Chris
this is why you got well that including
with your brother you know everybody
living forever REM is as thin in his
contract and his chain
like for me what if I could wave a magic
wand right now I would I would I would
probably wish for
a Kanye West album as soon as possible
before he gets back on his meds yes
I'm telling you who killed Jesus what I
would wave
unlike the other wanded wants mine could
actually happen
instead of waving my packet all the into
the CNN I think he'd make some dance
yeah and once you decide to look at what
is being sold to open your mind it is
amazing how obvious the game is Sir and
you have become so boring since you got
off CNN well you were better when you
were a [ __ ] cringy culture Warrior
guess what I have another one 77-20 now
to the perfect oh God we're doing calls
they do call-ins
fellas guys hear me out my wish please
has been great did I did do you want to
always do that you had a magic wand
I think I do because I don't think he'd
used to take calls you know we started
doing the big yes and now he's doing the
oh my God but wait Royce yeah it says
Chris and Bill I see a Chris who's this
bill let's check it out Dusty in the
control room what do you got
you know what happened they like the
segment
I'm telling you this what happened they
liked this segment and now that remember
how it used to be him and Don Lemon used
to do this you know crossover every once
in a while this is his this is his thing
but now it's Bill O'Reilly
it's so good God's been so good to us
this is so good God's been so sometimes
God does give her both hands Christ is
King I mean look at this
Bill O'Reilly looks like [ __ ] I thought
that was a madame tussle Wax Museum of
him I had no idea was really there you
know Madame Tussaud's uh statue that was
left in a hot car okay the call center
is flooded and
oh
I bet it is Mrs Denise from Flagler
Beach Florida oh my God so they take the
calls to so okay oh which is even better
hold on
because guys this is it I just called it
eighty three oh eight o'clock
eight o'clock uh what was yesterday
Eastern so eight o'clock uh Wednesday
was yesterday Wednesday Wednesdays at
eight o'clock Eastern on news Nation
you can call in
and if enough people call and you're
smart you have to be smart you could get
on and you could tell them that let's
get after it
look all we want is at least uh he has
to go [ __ ] bread yeah
if you guys let's go [ __ ] bread are
they live though it is it is no it's
live this is this is they do this live
please I need we got to go old school
man I need prank calls again like that
like the old days
Denise is it for me hi Chris or for the
big man both oh what is it
uh I'm a retired educator actually I
taught critical thinking in high school
and college
no you got what class is critical
thinking yeah you know you got in your
kids heads is what you're saying you
were probably an English teacher they
were like trying to [ __ ] you know
play with these kids Minds is what you
were doing
sixth grade and another he told me that
another student had brought a gun to
school and I reported it to the
administration they didn't take me
seriously at first I went to another
administrator the gun and then he shot
the kid just in case I was a little
worried so I shot the kid can't ever be
too careful here in Florida anyway so
what do you think about that is that
critical thinking found along with the
ammunition
I ask you both is this sixth grader evil
or is this just ineffective parenting
literally not enough information
especially for these two bozos to
[ __ ] answer it how do you even judge
that she wanted to shoehorn by the way a
story I believe is probably made up
um I mean I guess we could look it up
Flagger Flagler Beach right I guess I
don't know but I mean I I don't buy it
and then she's just trying to shoehorn
this gun in schools [ __ ] narrative
yeah
foreign
Denise first of all um you know
educators are um under praised in this
country no they're overpraised yeah
they're very much overpraised and under
work I think you believe you meant to
say underworked right right right I was
a high school teacher I don't know if
Cuomo knew at PACE in South Florida we
know do that or not and that's why my
grammar is better than his
um but when you have a tenure
them doing this little buddy back and
forth thing is going to give us I don't
it's I promise you
you have to you have to do this do you
know what he wants you know what they
want right here the new Hannity and
combs that's oh yeah oh yeah because
this is going to go from a segment to a
show there'll be a show now there'll be
a bill and a billing it bills bill will
be asked for for for billing for front
billing of course no they'll have to
come up with the name
like for the show because they'll fight
to the death about who should be top
build and they'll go find them we'll
call it like news Nations Prime Time
night special or something you know what
I mean like something without your names
then I guess
year old with a gun then that comes
under the age of Reason seven is
considered the Age of Reason but you
know that that kid is screwed up and but
that kid can take a life
um so it is not a black and white issue
well
statistically
um
I think we'll move on from this
um so you guys know late when they're
live listen I need this in my life I
need calls yes says go [ __ ] a Brett
Virgie is made would also be great